wait I remember why we stopped playing
this game because you were too stupid to
match my level of skill yeah that's what
it was I can't even argue right now
after what I just did oh hello everybody
my name is markiplier and welcome back
to 7 days to die with Wade hey guys so
uh we've had some trouble ok this is our
first offender for Adam oh is it
I distinctly remember some failures
failures there's no proof of the head I
I'm doing a slow fade into the past
these zombies there we go got one of
whoa it's got fast oh [ __ ]
hello hunting right Oh laughs [ __ ]
[ __ ] ass Jesus get up No holy [ __ ] I'm
infected [ __ ] man what does that mean I
don't know I got a torch on the second
floor oh boy oh she found the stairs oh
come on
die and then we can drop it Oh Dobby
we're over here
oh no you died the naked butt is eating
me how far away are you
I yeah yeah yeah yeah three kilometers
me it's not my fault it sounds like your
fault
yep those were that sucked didn't it Oh
God then I'd forgotten about those it
was so long ago
um but yeah so welcome back to seven
days to die ah we're here to do the
thing what man what what did we cover
this gay it's been two years that's
right it's been two years since we last
played this game which is astonishing
really yeah it is amazing how long it
has been I'm in love that's all you got
to say I know you said it before but you
can show I mean a lots changed in you
know times past we played other games
but it's really cool to come back and
revisit some of the some of the classics
yeah I mean there's this game has been
constantly updated because one of the
things in the last last time we play
this was this game was updated like
every two weeks or every week it was
really often that they would somehow
still an alpha though despite the fact
that it's been out for a long time yeah
how's that even possible still an alpha
but I mean hey whatever it is it is what
it is
wait where are you oh I'm not near you
oh I'm not near you at all oh no oh I
thought I was near you hang on I'm
a-coming
I'm a-coming where are you I'm just a
little to the south I thought I saw you
in a building but it turns out it was
not you it was something else
probably a zombie cuz I'm stupid hmm
don't be done what we stopped playing
this game you sure hi hello where are
you
over over there oh there you are hi hey
how's it going why do you look like I'm
stuck what do you mean what do you look
like I'm Stern why do you look like you
what do you mean like me you have
literally Einstein hair and an Einstein
handlebar mustache you are literally
Einstein I'll disguise myself a little
bit more really oh yeah oh yeah you're a
wise old wizard yeah trying to hide
yourself from me I see yeah well I got a
craft up all that stew I made us our
very own usable door Wow on the other
one Moo I'm very impressed our house
comes with a bed a fireplace one chair
and a box that sounds good I like that
okay oh I am a girl oh the cactus I need
to cut this down all right I'm trying to
how do I put on pants I never learned
that ski rest well in order to put on
pants in the real world you gotta press
the tab button and click on character I
got it I got it I got it again I got it
I got it I got it I go then you drag
them over to thee I get it well I got it
it's fine I'm gonna gather more wood
before it gets too late and we get died
okay okay
is it one zombie out here that's just
being a bit of a son of a [ __ ] yeah oh
yeah I've dealt with a few of those in
my time
hmmmm I need to craft a wooden club
apparently for my next trick apparently
I really don't know how long it's gonna
take to go through all the failure that
we've had so I don't know how long this
episode is or is going to be I don't
know either
yeah probably just best to cram it down
into just a minute or two right
probably episodes to be one minute no no
I mean the fail I mean you guys watching
don't need to know about anything since
is literally behind the scenes stuff
that isn't very important for you guys
watching but it's one minute of it
it's one minute of already show Durman
Oh show them again wasn't that good
before her shut up way they've already
seen it you don't need to confuse him
now oh yeah I could all captain yeah
okay oh this is lovely it's a little
cabin that's so nice oh that doesn't
sound nice sounds like there's something
outside I stepped on a cactus that's not
what I'm talking about
are you putting a bird nests bird nests
I found a few around the area I'm
looking for I need some feathers from a
bow and arrow yeah I found your friend
whoo hi friend
well that friend is very angry yeah I
got a club here try oh just stay down
for a minute there we go yeah the club
works better on these dudes yeah my club
broke ooh he's got hazmat boots that's
good is there a real look at the
transformation uh yeah that is bizarre
change okay yeah there's another there's
another one of that in our house is not
another that uh-huh so
oh it's there's no upstairs this is a
really tall area oh yeah this is all
we've got
yeah so anyway um the reason we're
playing this again is because I wanted
to play sir profit game with Wade and we
haven't played in a while but also I'm a
Comic Con right now so I wanted to get
another series to do while we were away
so this is what we're doing so that's
all my justification for it I didn't
know you were there how is that going
it's go I'm there right now it's so much
fun look at me
I'm dancing in the MS oh good you're
recording with me that's how this works
that's how time works when you're doing
things ahead no one needs to know any
different
yeah but I don't know it's also good to
just be doing a series again because I
haven't had a chance to do it before oh
that's right when we were balls in out
we were talking about Pokemon go we were
talking about that yeah team instinct
you joined the right team I did oh your
team instinct too yeah I don't think
anybody else's team is - you and I are
sheep it was so mad at me well people
right now when they find out that I'm
team instinct are like aw it's generally
disliked of it because this is [ __ ]
I can't believe it have any real
connection like people join based on
their favorite legendary bird for the
most part for me my favorites actually
Articuno which would be team mystic but
all my friends were joining instinct and
I was like well I'll go against the
grain here and then I got all the hate
for you yeah I know people do not like
it when you're not on their team you go
they don't it's really it's really
disconcerting for the state of society
if it's like you're a different color
than I am
[ __ ] you man oh I didn't think of it
like that because in your vision that's
pretty messed up it reminds me of when
uh you know reddit had this thing where
there was like team purple and team
orange or there was different words for
it but it was like that kind of team
thing going on and then it was randomly
assigned who was whose team so no one
ever picked but they instantly hated the
other team without even being told day
I'm like it became very like animalistic
with the amount of like disdain they had
for the other team just like
automatically from what you were
assigned to it was nuts and there's so
minimal interaction with other people
that I don't understand the hate anyway
well the only way you ever come across a
of them it's like gym battles right yeah
I mean pretty much which I haven't even
gotten a part of III just turned level
10 because I got in the game very late
yeah I'm 12
I'm not that pretty much further ahead
yeah I did get lucky because I found
an electric Eevee what's it called
Jolteon Jolteon yeah I found a Jolteon
and when I found it it was level 562 so
it was already like at a really high
level and I was able to upgrade it a
little bit so hopefully I'll be able to
fight at some lower gyms with that and
then maybe make some progress see I feel
weird about the thought of going to
battle at gyms because the open gyms
near me or it's like elementary schools
and I don't want to be that random 27
year old walking or driving to an
elementary school in the middle of
summer and parking in the parking lot
you know you know what's funny is you're
probably not the only one that would be
surrounded by adults it's it's just so
bizarre for like this game is just so
bizarre because I keep seeing videos of
people like in the middle of Central
Park and just like sprinting towards
like a Charizard that spawned by like a
tree somewhere randomly and there's like
people stampeding each other trying to
get this like one Charizard I've seen
videos I mean here in Cincinnati it's
not been like that but I've not been
downtown or anything but I've seen the
videos of like hordes of people going
running across like a crowded Street to
get to some Vaporeon or some random
pokemons
oh yeah yeah I I went down to Santa
Monica Pier recently because I was
trying to get some water Pokemon and
I've seen so many videos of like other
youtuber friends of mine that were down
there at a certain time oh [ __ ] it is
night yeah I would crouch and hide your
torch maybe so we don't attract any
unwanted attention okay
well it's super dark we need some light
to be able to see your beautiful face so
that we can talk to each other right Oh
your eyes are like yellow thanks man
I'm teaming sting through the look now
that I get close your cut just looks
like you're really high diamond sting
through yeah um but yeah so I went down
to Santa Monica but the like the second
I got there the server's went down like
it's just been unbelievable did you know
that game is made in unity no is it it's
made in unity which explains a lot of
the problems that pavement have it I
mean you and I have played some unity
games in my life and I I don't imagine
that's any better it's a really
beautiful things that on unity but there
are definitely a lot of problems with it
oh yes
what what's the new engine what's what's
the new thing people should be jumping
on oh man I mean unreal is like another
engine that people's do a lot of I don't
know what engine this game is built in I
think it's actually a custom engine that
they built but I'm yeah
unreal is like the most popular one
considering it's used by all of the all
of the major development companies
because it's so easy to split between
like ps4 and Xbox one and PC development
to do it simultaneous wheelie without
having to do much heavy lifting that
didn't sound good what is that I don't
know I don't hear it do you see like the
undetected icon
yeah the eye is really squinting okay
that's good that means we run detect
still okay good yeah so if it seems
boring it's because we're just waiting
out the night we have spent so much time
just trying to get to each other that we
just want to survive the night so that
we can go out and get supplies and start
building the rest'll yeah we're not
equipped to handle the running zombies
of the night oh yeah it is like it's
just instant death because they'll chase
you down you'll run out of stamina and
you'll just die so hopefully that won't
happen to us if we can manage to find a
way to craft beds we can spawn at the
beds and always manage to spawn back
here yeah we could do that I mean I can
make a bed roll right now
okay and you yeah you can make a bed
roll it's it's just plant fiber so I'm
gonna make that it's gonna take yeah
yeah yeah yeah but anyway back to the
more important subject of Pokemon go
yeah yeah yeah I I went down you when
you came over to LA you went to the
Americana which is a very nice place
it's where I used to live and in there
for some reason because Google Maps the
way it integrates things there's like
seven different landmarks in the
Americana
so there's seven different pokey stops
in the Americana which is awesome
because you just see everyone hanging
around the fountain just walking little
circles trying to find Pokemon and
taking advantage because everyone is
placing lures at all the pokey stops and
it's really cool so I just literally
would go there in super incognito by the
way cuz I don't wanna be subjected to
the entire horde of people there but uh
and then I just make little little
inconspicuous circles around the place
and collect all the Pokemon that I can
there's a park near where we used to go
to school
that has I think seven Pokemon stops and
a gym in it so we've been we've been
going over there and going for like long
walks and stuff oh that's nice I need to
go back to Cincinnati just to be able to
take advantage it's like my excuse for
going to see my friends again is only to
go collect Pokemon like this the only
reason that I want to go friends
messaging me about doing like trips
they're like hey we should go on a trip
sometime and it's like do you really
want to go to the beach they like no we
want to go Pokemon I mean there's
nothing wrong with it I guess it's a
good thing this is like such a huge
effect that it's like sweeping every
single aspect of humanity like it's
acting humanity on a social scale which
is so weird I mean they're a negative
like the people that are doing it at
work or running out into traffic and
stupid things like they're drugged doing
all driving but Oh God the positive
aspect to bring so many people together
getting them outside and walking is
fantastic yeah I can't tell you how many
people like would just stop and be like
hey there's there's like an Onix over in
that alley over there you should go get
it and it was like oh hey did you see
that Charizard over there it's like I'll
get that Magikarp over there is like Oh
everyone's so nice and helpful and this
is lovely and I like it of course I
don't think Cole spawns here just
wheedle Zand pidgeys but they do tell me
where those are oh yeah that's that's
pretty cool I guess I don't know it's
I've gotten the only things I've gotten
that Jolteon and I've got an anonymous
onix's spawn so how are you gonna get
enough to evolve it so yeah whatever but
that yeah that's true and you got a
hatch the eggs I guess get lucky that's
true that would be true but anyway it is
officially day so we survived the night
yeah and by walking out the front door
my skill and athletics has increased
congratulations man I'm really proud of
you so thank you thank you everybody so
much for watching I hope you enjoyed
this episode of failure and talking
about Pokemon go welcome to seven days
of Pokemon go is it booty butt go
but either way thank you everybody so
much we're gonna play this for a few
more episodes and have some fun with it
and get to crafting and hopefully not
die okay yeah so thanks again everybody
and check out Wade's channel in the
description below for other cool stuff
that we've done together
not the cool stuff that he's done so
thanks again and as always we'll see you
in the next video bye do you know how to
get us